saquon barkley say juan how are you pal
i'm doing good how are you doing i'm
doing great and we've enjoyed seeing you
in person the past couple years with the
super bowl it's kind of a strange
experience now it's always nice to be
around people directly what's been the
strangest aspect of this life in a
pandemic for you
uh
the strangest thing i mean it's just
kind of facing what everyone's facing
just
not being able to to go to the regular
world and kind of being locked in
in the house i guess you can say but um
even though it's been weird uh
definitely um there's a lot of positive
uh things that came from it you know you
could spend more time with where your
close uh close ones your loved one your
family
and it forced me to do some things
around the house that i was kind of
pushing aside and like for instance uh
to build a gym in my basements a place
where i could uh train last off-season
and now right here i'll see what my
rehab and and be able to rehab also too
strange football season two but the nfl
got all the games in and it came down to
the last weekend of the regular season
for your new york giants what's the
mindset among your teammates given that
the team was in play for a playoff berth
going into that final sunday
well i think you got to look at it as
the confidence has to be high especially
coming into next year
even though our record wasn't what we
wanted to be and we didn't start the
year how we wanted to start at the end
of the season we still had opportunity
to get in to make the playoffs and
that's honestly the goal um
everyone want to play for super bowl but
you can't do that without win your
division or without making to the
playoffs and we had opportunity uh we
played dallas
those boys came out and we balled and um
we came out which was basically a
playoff game for us and and won um
obviously the things didn't go the way
or we would like it but the mindset for
us is we gotta learn from that learn
from that experience don't put um our
future or our faith in another team
hands and um we gotta come off strong uh
really focus on this off season and then
um we're getting stronger getting ready
for the season and then obviously i
don't know what's going to happen with
otas and everything but when we are
allowed to get back together um really
focus and lock in and try to start off
right
you obviously have had a disappointing
season because of the injury what have
you learned the most about yourself
through the process of surgery rehab and
just not being able to do the thing you
love to do play football one i learned
i'm resilient
um you know you kind of think you are
and you kind of tell yourself you are
until a moment comes and and knocks you
knocks you on the ground um and you know
every single day i i know um how i'm
attacking it and i know my mindset and
trying to get one percent better every
single day with the help of my teammates
and help with trainers and patience you
know i'm a guy that always was trying to
go go go like let's go let's go and and
now you got to be smart especially
during the three hour process and um you
know it humbles you it humbles you you
know you got routine yourself how to
walk you gotta read you got you kind of
start you start starting square square
root you start from the floor all the
way up again um before you get all the
way up and stand up again so uh teaches
you it humbles you teaches you patients
and it shows that
i'm resilient not only am i saying i'm
brazilian i'm coming i'm showing myself
every day i'm having that um that
that battle i'm competing with myself um
every single day so far
saquon tell us how that experience turns
into
something tangible something positive
that you can use
to be a better player
when the time comes for you to put the
uniform on and go out there and carry
the football again well you get to see
the field differently
um watch it on tv or or watching it from
the stands or watching it from the uh
up in the booth you can see the the game
different um you have a different
appreciation of it uh just because it's
been taken away from you
and you know you you're forced to work
on things that you may have not worked
on before um you know you always say you
focus on the little things on the little
things but um you know you might just be
focusing you might be thinking you're
focusing on the little things and
attacking the weight room but you only
focus on all the big muscles you're not
focusing on all the little muscles that
that have a
a a key impact on how you are as an
athlete so um for me uh we're starting
from from ground zero all the way back
up um just focusing on the little things
and the things that i wasn't as good at
before um injury and try to improve that
and make that a strength and hopefully
whenever that time is again i'm on the
field
i can i can show that
i saw that you said recently that you
plan to do some workouts with otto
beckham jr he's obviously going through
the same thing how helpful is that to
have someone that you can compare notes
with right now real time not somebody
who did it last year the year before but
somebody who's doing it right now how
much does that help you yeah it
definitely helps i mean it helps to have
anyone that experiences injury um
whether i'm talking to
ap or even you know one of my college
buddy mark who tours acl um in college
and having conversations with him but oh
you know especially
someone that you know we respect each
other games but not only we respect each
other's games but we're really good
friends and um to be able to link up and
and have rehab together for a little bit
i think this is going to benefit both of
us
adrian peterson's the ultimate example
my goodness he tore his on christmas eve
and he was good to go week one the next
year and almost set the single season
rushing record what's he told you to do
and and to to how to handle this going
forward
um he told me you're gonna you're gonna
find out that you're gonna come better
from this um
wherever it's not just only football
but off the field whether it's in your
life
whether it's mentally
but also in football you become better
than this because you are
focusing you're forced to to train
muscles that you may have not been
training um as much as you should have
in the past um and you just get a
different understanding of the
understanding of your body um so for me
it was just asking a lot of questions uh
with the doctors and the trainers and
then and seeing where you know the the
steps that they want me to take um and
how much they want to improve and and
attacking it and you gotta attack it but
you gotta tackle smarter and that's
something that he told me and um i'm
very fortunate to be able to have a guy
like that that i can reach out and call
at any single time and know exactly
where he was throughout his uh his rehab
process
we just finished covering a hiring cycle
of seven new nfl head coaches just a
year ago joe judge was one of the new
hires there's still a lot of people that
don't really know what to make of joe
judge and what kind of a coach he's
going to be how would you describe your
head coach to someone who doesn't know
him
um he's a guy that's going to come in
here and get the best out of all his
players um and it's not just from what
he's going to say he's going to show it
and he's going to get the best out
you're going to push you um you know
when you come to work every single day
you're going to find something that
you're going to get better
whether it's on the football field or
whether it's in the playbook or whether
it's just understanding of the game as a
whole um you know
even if you you may be a well-known
running back but you're going to know
special teams um you may be a well-known
quarterback for you on those special
teams you're going to know you're going
no defense going no special teams but we
all gonna know uh what we got to do
because at the end of the day football
is a complimentary game and that's the
kind of coach that um i don't think i
know that we have um and i'm very
excited i wish um obviously i i could
have done a little bit more this year
but
hopefully next year when i'm able to get
back with the team
you know hopefully we can show everyone
what we really got
you've got three years in your nfl
career and you've shown that you can be
among the very best nfl running backs
the windows open for a second contract
you and the team have any understanding
about
when that's going to happen is there
going to be negotiation this off season
or does everybody just kind of want to
wait and see what happens in 2021 um to
be honest uh
that's at least my worries and then
that's claiming on my mind right now um
to even have that conversation spark
that conversation up i'm really just
focusing on uh you know getting getting
this knee ready um
because you know i want to be the best
player that i can be hopefully better
than i ever was for near johns
well one of the benefits of being a
great player opportunities to make money
elsewhere such as being a spokesman for
oikos tell us what you have going on
with them
yeah oikos they're coming out with a
commercial going super ball uh the pro
face commercial um and the pro face kind
of just stands for uh what will you do
as an athlete or or a trainer or or
anyone who goes in in a weight room it's
that face that you make when you're
grinding when you're showing that raw
emotion that attention motion where
you're trying to set a pr record uh in
the weight room whether it's bench
weather squat um so that that's adobo
concept that i believe that they came up
with and i would say they're also doing
a program for trainers
in america where
you are able to
sign up to originalsproforpros.com
as a trainer
and be able to get profits 100 profits
actually
in february uh whoever was able to to
donate and then also up to a thousand
dollars um for trainers so especially
what's going on in this world and the
pandemic i think that's very cool uh
what oracle's doing and i'm happy and
proud to be able to say that i'm a line
and partnering up with them all right
you got to show us your face then what's
your face what's your pr face
oh man don't put me on the spot uh
my face the best thing i say uh you i
think uh i believe it's on super bowl
but uh you'll be able to see it on the
screen
hey uh chris godwin your former teammate
at penn state's going for a super bowl
ring are you pulling for one team or the
other you know you got friendships all
throughout the league who are you who
are you rooting for in this game coming
up on sunday um not real for anyone i
know uh i wish i do wish the best for uh
for rod uh for chris godwin and um but i
think it would be cool for tom brady to
get his seventh ring um
so i would say i probably if i had to
pick
uh which i've been forced to pick a
couple of times i i would say i'm
picking up brady in the bucks
all right well hey say quan it's great
talking to you we wish you all the best
we look forward to seeing you back on
the field we look forward to see that
face the commercial coming up during the
game on sunday thanks pal thank you
thank you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports